good morning Hank it's Tuesday so 2016
seems destined to be remembered as the
year of the dumpster fire but I don't
really think that's fair because like
anything 2016 is vast and it contains
multitudes like really 2016 wasn't even
one year with seven point four billion
different years - seven point four
billion different people
anyway Rosie Auto recently asked her
viewers to share their best of 2016 and
I found it so encouraging to hear about
all the wonderful experiences people had
this year so I thought today I would
share my four favorite memories of 2016
first I got to attend the 100th running
of the Indy 500 with my mom and dad and
lots of our friends now I know that the
Indy 500 is technically just 800 left
turns half of which you can't see
because the track is so huge but it is
also the largest non-religious gathering
of human beings on earth and while I'm
not usually a crowds person it is truly
wondrous to see so many different people
come together and then I left the Indy
500 drove to the airport and boarded a
plane to go to London where I got to see
nerdfighteria sponsored AFC Wimbledon
play at Wembley for a spot in the third
tier of English football a game which
they won and then sleepless and
delirious I returned to Wimbledon's home
stadium to party with my dad and friends
and strangers and AFC Wimbledon players
and it was just magical now again one
could easily say how can you get so
excited about the 82nd best football
team in England and to those people I
would say at the moment AFC Wimbledon
are actually the 55th best football team
in England second great memory of 2016
sarah's cousin getting married in
Portland Oregon
so when Sarah and I were in our 20s we
sometimes went to seven or eight
weddings a year and frankly I came to
dread them because you know I just like
formalwear and banquet food and making
small talk with strangers and overly
long toasts and most of all dancing but
now that we've reached an age where
weddings are few and far between I've
really come around to them and this one
in particular had me both laughing and
crying I'd known the groom since he was
in high school the couple were lovely
and generous to each other and to their
guests he was so fun to watch my kids
watch a wedding because they were just
like dad what is happening and best of
all after the wedding we got to go to a
Portland Timbers game third grade memory
of 2016 meeting baby Oren in Montana
Hank I don't want to taunt you by
bragging about experiences that you
can't have but there is nothing like the
pride and happiness of seeing your baby
brother be
a committed and loving father Hank in
your life you've been good at many
things but when I was visiting with you
and Catherine in Oran in Montana I
thought he's found the thing that he's
best at okay enough sentimentality so
far all my favorite memories of 2016
involved leaving Indianapolis and that
that's not a good sign and while I do
dearly love our Airport named best
airport in America four years running I
think my favorite memory of this year
was being home in both 2014 and 2015 I
spent more than a hundred days away from
home this year I was home nine nights
out of ten that meant more time for
writing and more time with my family and
while I think quality time with your
kids is incredibly important there's
also something to be said for quantity
time and this was an awesome year to be
a dad Henry learned how to ride a bike
Alice learned her ABC's they both
learned every single word to Moana and I
was home for most of it which was the
best thing to happen to me this year
other than AFC Wimbledon's promotion
nerdfighters if you'd like to share your
best of 2016 please do so in comments or
make a video and link to it in comments
Hank when you see me next it will be
2017 meaning that the vlogbrothers
channel will be celebrating its 10th
anniversary thank you for doing this
with me for a decade what a long strange
trip it has been I will see you on
Tuesday Friday dang it so bad at days
are you gonna wearing that green
when you're gonna get your days down huh
I've reached that age where my son has
suddenly surpassed me an ability to tell
what day of the week it is